[Music]
you're saying it's on can you hear me
now
no
can you hear me now
some of the others are on the chair
oh my god
testing testing
can you hear can you hear that
slightly it's a bit better but
can we go up a bit more
i'm going to oh that's i think we're in
right good afternoon
uh just so that you know for uh rules of
debate for this meeting i am going to um
suggest that people remain seated
and so that the microphones hopefully
will be able to pick up your voices
so um we will for this meeting
remain in seats
so we start with item one apologies for
absence i've had apologies from
councillors dayton
gomezrini
hill
row
and windly
are there any other apologies
council kenyan
council foster and travel thank you a
foster councillor
any other apologies of names from the
past
no
thank you
so much to item 2 then declarations of
interest members are requested to
declare the existence and nature of any
disposable pecuniary interest
and or other interests not already on
their register of interest in any item
on the agenda and withdraw from the
meeting at the appropriate time so just
to stop
this off i'm going to declare an
interest item 12 as a written old
director
counselor
welton
uh yes i'd also like to
uh declare the same and ask a question
about whether as a written director i'll
need to withdraw um at the appropriate
moment in the uh
yes we do okay council club
thank you chair uh yeah item 12 regional
board thank you council roof
item 12 written on board thank you
counselor
hall
yeah
agenda item a mandatory cctv in taxis i
hold a taxi badge issued by a different
council so i'll withdraw from the
meeting thank you council hall thank you
any others
we moved to item three minutes of the
last meeting so the minutes of the
meeting held on the 12th of july 2021
have been circulated so this is to
approve them as a correct record do we
have a proposal please
counselor dale
seconded by council cupid
councillor barry chair can i come in on
on the minutes um
at the end it'd be nice to have the
dates of future meetings and i'm asking
as to whether we can confirm that the
meeting for the next full council is
still going to be on the 29th of
november i'm not going to be moved
yes chair we can do that that's it
that's fine
so it has been moved and seconded all
those in favor
[Music]
anyone against
the abstentions
not that's carried thank you
item four chairman's announcements
everyone here will be aware of the
shocking news concerning the loss of
life in killer marsh recently
the tragic deaths of john paul bennett
aged 13
lacey bennett aged 11
their mother terry harris
and lisa's friend connie gent aged 11
are difficult to comprehend
the thoughts of this council are with
all those in killer marsh and beyond who
have been affected by what has happened
particularly with the families and
friends of those who have died
i ask that you join with me in silent
reflection
to demonstrate solidarity with the
community of killer marsh
thank you
this is also with sadness that i have to
inform council of the death of the
former councillor for ashover
peter ramshaw
those of you on council that remember
peter will know that
he was a man with
a great sense of humor
[Music]
a man who was determined to
do his best for the ward that he
represented
but also somebody who
stuck to his own opinions and made sure
that
he valued others
but presented his views accordingly a
man of great intelligence and integrity
so please again
a pause for reflection in remembrance of
peter ramshaw
and that this council conveys its very
best wishes to his family and friends
thank you colleagues
mayor welcome to council
council bentley strafford stevenson and
councillor tony lacy
congratulations on your election success
in the wards of barlow and homesfield
and killer marsh east respectively
thank you to the councillors and
officers who attended the civic service
on the 26th of september
it was a wonderful occasion that
showcased several representative groups
from north east derbyshire
i was especially pleased to see those
from the deaf community who were able to
access the service thanks to a bsl
interpreter
it really was something special
the event on the 3rd of october
demonstrating the council's commitment
to the armed forces covenant was an
opportunity to signal all we do for
those linked to military service in some
way
the council has a positive record for
supporting reservists veterans those who
are serving and their families
i received a message last night from the
vice lord lieutenant of derbyshire
congratulating the council and all it
does for the serving community and their
thanks to elected members and officers
jean and i were invited to the
inauguration of peter shellhouse as land
rat of darmstadt dieberg
it was three days of touring council
facilities
a school meetings with representative
groups and civic engagements
the days of twinning as we once knew
them are a thing of the past
it was agreed that our communities would
explore a partnership
to share ideas about economy
employment and training
develop education programs and discuss
approaches to climate change
and before anyone asks gene and i paid
our own way
so council taxpayers didn't foot the
bill
i am grateful to those who are
supporting fundraising for my appeal for
ashgate hospice care
since the last meeting of full council
there has been a cricket match
brilliantly supported by staff from
naddc
and ritnald holmes
an abba tribute night and tour of
tissington
people of holy moore side also rallied
to stage a fantastic community event
that was heartwarming to say the least
my next event is this friday evening
it'd be great to see you at my brass
band concert and you've all got a flyer
on your tables
which promises to be an entertaining
night
thank you
item five leaders announcements council
dale thank you thank you chad is
everyone able to hear me through the mic
is that working
over here
oh
hello is that working brilliant thank
you very much jeff um firstly just to
echo uh your words chair in in offering
the condolences to the family friends
and all residents across killer marsh
um i laid flowers alongside councillor
welton and councillor clough as uh as
chair of uh wrigle board and chair of
killermarsh parish council
shortly after the events to pay our
collective respects uh to the family and
and friends and loved ones at the
council and ricknall they're continuing
to support the police with their
investigations
and the village is still clearly coming
to terms with what's happened
but i want all residents to know that we
stand with you and we are here for you
as a district council
ricknald has already been supporting
many of the neighbouring residents
but if there are any residents who still
need to support um i urge them to get in
touch with us and we will obviously
provide support that we can or signpost
for those who can't i also want to echo
your warm words of uh of welcome to
councillor stratfor stevenson and
council lacey many congratulations to
both of you and we look forward to
working with you
moving forward
i want to touch briefly on the on the
local plan i'm sure
many of you will be aware that the
inspector's final report has now been
received and that our mp lee rowley has
subsequently written to the secretary of
state to request that it is reviewed we
therefore have to allow that process to
transpire
before it can be brought before full
council for a vote on the adoption i'm
not clear exactly when that will take
place but it's assumed that that will
probably be at the next meeting in
november
in terms of leisure it's been an
extremely busy past couple of months for
the leisure service
with major refurbishment works taking
place at eckington we were successful in
securing a one million pound grant from
the government which is helping us to
make significant improvements such as
re-lining the pool replacing the windows
and doors and installing air sorts heat
heat pumps
it's helping us to achieve our climate
change commitments whilst also making
the pool one of the most environmentally
friendly and low carbon in the country
at killer marsh preliminary works are
already taking place with major works
expected to commence imminently
which will realize the council's 1.9
million pound investment in the facility
transforming its fortunes and helping to
secure its future as a much-loved
community hub for the village
and as we're all aware the clay
crosstown deal is progressing as part of
which we are still working on our plans
for the redevelopment of charlie park
leisure centre
um the council and wriggled homes are
also working at speed to refurbish over
320 council properties across the
district having secured the 1.5 million
green homes grant from the government to
this we've added 8.5 million of our own
funds and the works include structural
improvements helping to prolong the life
of some of our most at-risk
non-traditional construction properties
as well as the retrofitting of external
wall insulation which has multiple
benefits including making the properties
warmer bringing down the cost of energy
bills for our tenants and helping us to
meet our climate change commitments
we're very grateful to the residents of
uh for bearing with us during any
destruction caused by either the works
at atkington or killer marsh leisure
centres as well as the green homes grant
works
moving on to the afghanistan situation i
think you'll all join me in saying how
concerning and troubling it was to see
what happened and what unfolded over the
summer
the government were quite quick to
request support from all councils
in providing accommodation to meet the
needs
in particular of interpreters who
supported the british military during
our occupation of the country
and the request from the government was
a modest offer
from every council i i believe they were
working on the principle of every little
helps
i'm pleased to inform members that we
have therefore offered two three bed
properties in the first instance and we
are currently awaiting direction from
the government about when and where the
offer will be activated and that offer
is in line with other district councils
we're also lately aiding on behalf of
residents about private rented office uh
particularly those people who have
generously come forward with their
desire to support afghan families
at this time
i also want to reiterate the huge thank
you to officers and members for
supporting and helping to organise some
some recent events including our meet
the council event in eckington last
monday and now that the covered
restrictions have eased it's been
fantastic to get out into our
communities and give residents the
opportunity to learn more about the
services that the district council
provides and hear from residents about
their views on some of the key issues
facing their communities it's a key part
of our commitment to be a listening
council and therefore it's the first of
many to come including a session
tomorrow evening at clay cross and
finally a big thank you to council
athaka in particular the partnerships
team for all of their excellent
organisation of our armed forces
covenant event yesterday as you say in
drumfield which i think went
tremendously well and really was enjoyed
by all those who attended thank you
chair thank you
thank you so much to item six public
participation no questions have been
submitted so item seven
political balance and amendments to
committees i'm going to invite nikki
calver the governance manager to present
the report please
thank you chairman
can everyone hear me okay thank you um
when the political balance of the
council changes such as after a
by-election council are required to
consider the proportional balance as is
recommended best fit
the changes offer only an alteration to
the standards committee composition
it is on this proportionality that
appointments to committees are made
and these are received to date and
they're set out in the appendices to the
report amendments and appointments can
be moved by group leaders as required
further the current outside bodies list
is attached to the report and can be
amended verbally as members see fit
through you chair i'll be happy to help
with any questions
any comments or questions
a question
so no comments or questions then so we
move to proposal counter dale
thank you
um can i move that we replace uh
councillor a platz with councillor b
stratford stevenson on growth scrutiny
um
and
also to replace councillor r welton with
councillor d drabble on organization
scrutiny
uh and then just on the outside bodies
list i think this hack this change has
already taken place but i noticed it was
out of date which is to replace
councillor a hutchinson
with myself councillor a dale
for northwood group limited on the
outside bodies list and also i've
noticed that the groundwork trust
has now been dissolved
and so i think it needs to be removed
from the outside bodies list and i was
going to suggest um speaking with nikki
outside of the meeting that a we do a
bit of a review of the outside bodies
list because i'm conscious that there
are probably some that are out there out
of date as well and you could probably
refresh those
thank you
do you have a second for those changes
thank you council cupid
so you've seen the recommendations at
page 19. do we have a mover for the
recommendations
council dale because they were about
nominations for changes so thank you and
the second for the recommendations to
set out council cupid thank you all in
favor
anyone against
any abstentions
no thank you that's carried
i'm sorry sir
council lily
i'm really struggling to hear from
microphones on the floor so maybe we can
do something about it otherwise i'm i
might as well put my apologies in
because i can't i can't hear i can't
take it around
i think it's difficult i think to be
honest counselor lily i don't think the
acoustics in this room are good for
anyone
and i don't think the the microphones
are working for most people here so i
wouldn't want you to feel that it's just
for you
this is we're all struggling with it
i'm trying to read lips as it sounds at
the moment
so yeah i mean
most of what alex said i didn't hear
right
it may come up in reference in other
areas of the agenda and basically i'm
not right now
is there any way that
we could
move the room that would best suit you
so you can see people's faces
you want this you want to come on the
front
not really because
i mean supposing the the the mainstay of
the is that the meeting is just help i
can hear you plain as day but it's the
microphones down here that i'm really
really struggling with even though i
might hear the sound it's distorted to
such an extent
i accept what you say is anything from
the technician's point of view we can do
to improve this
[Music]
[Music]
no that's not working even now
[Music]
is
[Music]
right
that's not criticism it's just this is
the difficulty with modern technology
and this is not the right venue
it's like being back at school in an
exam room
and it's bringing back awful memories
for me
but i think you know from an inclusion
point of view this is a nightmare
so apologies counselor lilly if you want
move to somewhere you're welcome to join
me i know that's another nightmare for
people but you're welcome to join me
here
so you want to give it try it a bit
longer
well i'm sorry that you're having this
experience and thank you for your
patience
thank
you so we're moving to um item eight
which is about mandatory cctv and taxes
so i'm going to ask the um
council solicitor and deputy monitoring
officer mr kevin chilito to present the
report please
chair i understand that council is
foster and leaguer to actually
lead on this one
chair can you hear me i understand that
councillors foster and leaguers are
going to present this report
no you're going to present the report mr
shilito you're the
the officer so could we ask you just to
say a few words and then we'll open it
up for elected members to speak i'm
happy i'm happy to introduce it um
as several members on this uh council
are already aware of this matter has
been before uh scrutiny one of the
scrutiny committees and licensing
committee and through a public
consultation exercise what we've
ended up with is a policy for mandatory
cctv and taxes
that reflects the government guidance
that was introduced last year
prior to that guidance we had um
from a legal point of view
such a policy would have been difficult
to introduce and we had to maintain the
status quo
but thankfully with the government
guidance coming into force we've now
been able to put together a policy that
should
[Music]
act as a preventative measure from the
community safety
point of view
i'm not going to go through the report
in detail but if there are any questions
i think mr shelton we really are
struggling to hear you um i think the
report has been circulated i think the
best thing to do is take some comments
or questions
um are there any comments or questions
council shipment
thank you hello is that coming out yeah
thank you chair um
i mean great great policy it's a good
job that we're adopting it but one of my
concerns is that taxi drivers can still
go and get licensed in chesterfield or
balls over or sheffield
apart from that
what we can do and we made this point
this was brought up in licensing and
it's a very valid point this was brought
up and discussed in licensing and what
we said we'd do we admit we'd make it as
public as possible make sure that all
our public knew in northeast that when
they were going to hire a taxi that they
would hire it from someone licensed in
this area it was also a concern when it
came to uh losing uh
lack of business for our taxi holders
and that nobody renewed in this area so
all those things were brought up and
discussed at length
uh in in licensing and that's by all
political groups so you all had
representation there uh and you made the
point um
councillor shipman it was brought up by
councilwoman she made exactly the same
and it was answered in licensing so
that's where it was discussed before it
was brought here so we did cover that
point in full
now when it comes to this policy overall
uh it's all well and good making a song
and dance about it now but this was
first recommended from a scrutiny
committee in 2017 when i was in
opposition
and i can see uh councillors not in the
uh not in the heads to this and i know
our chair at the time we put it forward
what happened is these recommendations
went through to the then cabinet and
they then didn't put them forward they
rejected the idea of mandatory cctv
now it's all well and good now it's on
everybody's mind right now because
there's been events in the news this
year when people have been at risk not
quite shaking your head there's been
it's been in the news when people have
been at risk and people have come under
uh people vulnerable people i'm not
going to mention names but throughout
the country where it could have helped
them it's all as good as making a song
and dance about it now but this should
have happened back then this should be
should have been a step towards it back
then
absolutely it should have been done in
2018 it would have been a courageous
decision back then and that's when it
should have been it was rejected
by a cabinet then no point shaking your
head over there so what i'm hoping that
this time around
it was a recommendation and it's in the
minutes
what i'm hoping that this time the same
people that voted against it last time
and didn't want it to go through
actually see fit at this meeting to vote
this through this is an opportunity to
vote this through now and make the
people in our community much safer
thank you chair
you council liggett
i'd also like to say um i have actually
spoken to local taxi drivers and i was
quite shocked by how much they were in
favor of it because they said it would
also make their life safer
any other comments or questions
how to dale
yeah
thank you chad um happy to to second
assuming no one else already has um just
an answer to the point around other
councils it is a fair fair comment um
other councils haven't yet introduced
this and uh that will always be the case
around licensing that um you know as a
taxi driver you are able to go
to a different area to get your license
and still operate across the country but
i think the key thing and we all have a
letter on our desks from the from the
police and crime commissioner um
congratulating us on uh taking this move
um and the key thing is about urging
fellow councils to follow suit i think
that's the um you know it's right it's
not mandatory technically there are
there are some grounds within the
guidance to allow councils not to do it
but i think it's it's incumbent upon us
if we all support this policy uh to do
what we can to help encourage other
councils to follow suit so that's
certainly what i'll be doing and
following the lead from councillor
foster who has sent this sent this
letter to us all
who any others
have spoken council liggett so that's it
it's been proposed and seconded
[Music]
and so put it to the vote all those in
favor
[Music]
anyone
against any abstentions
and it's carried thank you
so we move to item nine to answer any
questions from members asked under
procedure rule 9.2
we do have a question uh submitted by
councillor hancock to councillor parking
or would you please counsel hancock
thank you chair and if i if i may also
pass thanks from council ramshaw's
family to you selfie kind words earlier
question two sorry
[Music]
so so question to to counsellor parking
we note the increased cost of taking
recycling in-house along with several
internal restructures over the last two
years and the potential cost of taking
on killer marsh sports centre
and i think it's fair to say that all
members have significant concerns as to
how the council will balance its budget
over the medium term
for the last couple of years council has
been provided with reference to
unidentified savings can council parking
providers with a clear proposal as to
how he intends to balance the
medium-term financial plan
thank you council parking
uh just wait until uh i make sure we can
we can hear thank you jeff
uh so thank you for your question
council hancock um
it's nice to be able to speak in council
because i don't get very many questions
but in this case i thank you for the
question
it has unfortunate timing but we'll come
to that
and so i'll be happy to provide you with
a clear proposal
and that that will of course be as part
of the annual budget setting process
as colleagues will be aware the budget
cycle starts in september
and concludes with a recommendation from
cabinet council to approve the budget
each january
i will either i will therefore reserve
the right to pla to provide the plan
that council hancock has requested until
that point
i will however give you some insight
into
some of the work that is currently being
undertaken
significant progress
is being made
with our growth agenda
aimed at regenerating and bringing
income into the district
investment and assets forums have been
established
with work plans aimed at
making our assets work we can't hear
your council parking at this side all
right
i know you just said yeah can we
just try again sorry
i'll
i'll i'll look at you so that no no
we've got other councillors can't hear
you all right
as you'll see whether that's any better
can we hear okay now on the left is that
better transforming its fortunes and
helping to secure its future as a
much-loved community hub for the village
and as we're all aware the clay
crosstown deal is progressing as part of
which we are still working on our plans
for the redevelopment of charlie park
leisure centre
the council and wriglet homes are also
working at speed to refurbish over 320
council properties across the district
having secured the 1.5 million green
homes grant from the government to this
we've added 8.5 million of our own funds
and the works include structural
improvements helping to prolong the life
of some of our most at risk
non-traditional construction properties
as well as the retrofitting of external
wall insulation which has multiple
benefits including making the properties
warmer bringing down the cost of energy
bills for our tenants and helping us to
meet our climate change commitments
we're very grateful to the residents of
uh for bearing with us during any
disruption caused by either the works at
atkington or killer marsh leisure
centres as well as the green homes grant
works
moving on to the afghanistan situation i
think you'll all join me in in saying
how concerning and troubling it was to
see what happened and what unfolded over
the summer
the government were quite quick to
request support from all councils
in providing accommodation to meet the
needs
in particular of interpreters who
supported the british military during
our occupation of the country
and the request from the government was
a modest offer
from every council i i believe they were
working on the principle of of every
little helps
i'm pleased to inform members that we
have therefore offered two three bed
properties in the first instance and we
are currently awaiting direction from
the government about when and where the
offer will be activated and that offer
is in line with other district councils
we're also lately aiding on behalf of
residents about private rented office
particularly those people who have
generously come forward with their
desire to support afghan families
at this time
i also want to reiterate the huge thank
you to officers and members for
supporting and helping to organise some
some recent events including our meet
the council event in eckington last
monday
now that the covered restrictions have
eased it's been fantastic to get out
into our communities and give residents
the opportunity to learn more about the
services that the district council
provides and hear from residents about
their views on some of the key issues
facing their communities it's a key part
of our commitment to be a listening
council and therefore it's the first of
many to come including a session
tomorrow evening at clay cross
and finally a big thank you to
councillor thacker and particularly the
partnerships team for all of their
excellent organisation of our armed
forces covenant event yesterday as you
say in drumfield which i think went
tremendously well and really was enjoyed
by all those who attended thank you
chair thank you
thank you so much item six public
participation no questions have been
submitted so item seven
the political balance and amendments to
committees i'm going to invite nikki
calver the governance manager to present
the report please
thank you chairman
can everyone hear me okay thank you um
when the political balance of the
council changes such as after a
by-election council are required to
consider the proportional balance as is
recommended best fit
the changes offer only an alteration to
the standards committee composition
it is on this proportionality that
appointments to committees are made
and these are received to date and
they're set out in the appendices to the
report here and historically we have
never failed to meet our savior's target
by the end of the year
and we intend to do the same this year
this is not to say that we're complacent
we are fully aware of the magnitude of
the challenge facing us
and
we'll all be working hard to address
this
but i would like to point out a couple
of challenges that we face in this task
more recent challenges
so fuel and utility costs are rising i
think we're all aware of that we're
perhaps also aware of availability
issues
but
particularly gas and
petroleum fuel very difficult at the
moment
um
however
the second one i'd like to point out is
the ongoing
impact of covet
in
the ongoing impact of coved
it's having a detrimental impact on our
ability to raise local taxation through
business rates
okay so budgets are dependent upon
central government settlements and other
funding we are expecting clarity on
funding settlements from government in
the near future
you can be sure that we will be
encouraging our new secretary of state
to provide appropriate funding for the
important work that councils do
so to conclude i'm fully aware of the
challenges we face i am optimistic of
delivering
another balanced budget to the council
in january
thank you a supplementary question
councillor hancock
thank you chair
and thank you council parking i'm not
actually sure it it answered although
apologies because i couldn't hear
everything
i'm glad you're expecting clarity and so
from from central government because
that's kind of what i'm asking for you
set from yourself as well
can you give me assurance that when we
have the budget term delivered to us
that we won't have references to
unidentified savings and that we will
actually have detailed proposals in it
covering every aspect
council parking
thank you for the supplementary question
council hancock um i
i can assure you that our budget papers
will include all the necessary
supporting materials
as required
by
thank you chair
thank you so we move to item 10 to
consider any motions from members under
procedure rule number 10
we have two motions that have been
submitted today so the first one is from
councillor shipman
council shipman
are we on is that coming out okay yeah
um
so i've tried to put a bit of detail in
this motion because members might not be
familiar with the background of what's
happening on twai lane and the
subsequent events that have unfolded
i don't want this to be a debate about
whether the application needs revoking
or not this is simply the only mechanism
that's available to get
that agenda item on the planning
committee i have spoke to officers and
tried every other way of getting it
there so it can be looked at
independently by the blind community and
the decision can be made once both sides
have heard all the information that's
now available obviously when it was
first approved
there's been information that's come to
light since then
that's to do with the flooding team ask
for a series of different surveys to
build et cetera on the site and we are
where we are today where nothing can be
done in terms of planning enforcement
and this is the only available mechanism
left to try and get that debate back on
the plane committee so i would like to
move this motion in its entirety so it
can be debated by the planning committee
and like i say both sides of the
arguments can be heard again
do we have a second uh council reader
yes chair i'm going to fully second this
motion
i want to sort of say right now
that clay cross members are fully
supportive of the people on clay lane
and
in terms of district councillors all of
all of the district councillors have
made their objections
to that application going in in the
first instance the parish council did
the same and we fully stand behind all
of those residents that are raising the
issues so i fully support this motion
and i'm happy to second it
thank you any other comments
council cupid
[Music]
so i completely appreciate and
understand
the concerns of local residents here and
members and i think this is an important
opportunity today and the first of many
upcoming to discuss these concerns in
this situation and set the record
straight on a few things
to get to the heart of what i think
you're trying to do with this motion
also appreciate you're asking for it to
go to committee to ask for the
consideration of the revocation of
permission on this site i think that's
premature
i have no issue with trump championing
the revocation of an application if it's
justified as indeed i and my group have
previously when a former labour member
progressed an application against
officer recommendations in my ward and
the previous administration weren't even
willing to debate it
however in this case i think potential
solutions are on the table and should be
fully considered
on this note i asked councillor shipman
what have you actually done to try and
resolve residents concerns here in terms
of active actions it's quite easy to put
forward this motion to defer action and
decision to this chamber and to the
committee without consideration of the
consequences of what you're proposing
and to use emotive language on social
media and in the press but what have you
done to try and find a practical
solution rather than grab the headlines
as cabinet member for planning i haven't
had any direct contact from you to raise
or discuss this issue but it was raised
with me by lee rowley mp on behalf of
residents
as a result over the last few months lee
and i have had countless meetings with
planning legal and enforcement officers
and the flood authority at the county
council to try and fully understand
their comments and the issues which has
included escalating the issue to the
head of the department and his relevant
director so all options could be
reviewed seven trent are also involved
as i understand some of the flooding
concerns relate to drainage and sewage
similarly in line with the email that
was sent to both of us and the local
ward members on the 30th of july by the
developer offering to discuss concerns
and try to find a way forward lee and i
have had several meetings with the
developer which has included their chief
executive and chairman to outline the
concerns being raised by residents have
you also done this
as a result of these meetings and i
think it would be fair to say some
robust conversations on all sides and i
thank all those involved i understand
the developer has looked at ways to try
and resolve the concerns has recently
hired an external consultant to do an
additional in-depth assessment of the
brook using data accepted and recognized
by the ea and the llfa and an additional
100 metre cubed overflow water storage
tank has now been proposed for the north
west corner these were finalized last
week and are now on the relevant
application page
i openly admit i'm not a technical
expert but neither are you that i'm
aware of and so i think the right
way forward is to await the flood
authority's formal analysis and comments
on this on on the changes and when
they've reached a position the section
73 application which is needed to vary
the layout of the site will already then
go to planning committee as it was
already called in a long time ago by
yourself
in advance of that i understand both the
developer and flood authority have also
agreed to have a meeting with residents
to have an open discussion on these new
proposals
i view this approach as the best way
forward beginning proceedings to revoke
an application puts the process over to
an inquiry which has no guarantees
either way as we all know
in particular given that this site was
allocated in the local plan by the
previous administration a fact i know
some labour members seem to have
forgotten and that the developer seems
willing to engage through the new
mitigation measures proposed or similar
and in open discussions they're willing
to reach out their hand a revocation and
inquiry would not be justified at the
moment and could take actually take the
situation backwards
so to summarize whilst i always keep the
option on any development of
modification or revocation on any
application open i cannot support this
motion at the current time as i believe
there are other better ways to resolve
residence concerns and i'd urge you to
withdraw it i think we should have the
residence meeting with the developer and
flood authority to discuss the new
analysis and proposals await the formal
and independent technical view of the
flood authority on the proposal of the
additional tank in the northwest corner
and then the planning committee can
debate and decide the section 73
application on the basis of this with
everyone able to put forward their views
at this point as you've asked i'm going
to continue to go for action rather than
words here to try and resolve this and i
hope you'll you'll join me in that thank
you chair
thank you any other comments
counselor off
thank you i don't know if you can hear
me
or not
okay
in response to the motion raised by
councillor shipman regarding the
development for clay lane
historically as we've heard this was
included in the emerging local plan by
the labour group
the application for clay lane was heard
by committee in march 2020
this was a lengthy meeting with
arguments both for and against the
development
after much debate and based on the
evidence put before the committee the
application was given approval
since then we have all learned that
fresh issues had been identified
we have now heard from councillor cupit
working alongside our mp lee rowley and
the developer that an appropriate
solution to address concerns regarding
the potential flooding in principle have
potentially been identified
i am happy that these further proposals
will come to the committee for
consideration in due course
and i will consider these at the time
with an open mind
i would also like to take this
opportunity to comment on the strong and
potentially offensive public comments
that you have made about the council's
enforcement officers
and actions
as the motion before receiver notes the
council has taken enforcement action
where relevant on other issues and
continues to put a lot of effort into
resolving any concerns
[Music]
as elected members we always have strong
debate and hold one another to account
but we should do so with appropriate
language especially where our officers
doing their jobs are concerned
i for one will not be supporting this
motion thank you
you're the comments
councillor foster
uh thank you chair yeah just a quick one
from me uh i sat on the planning
committee and um councillor rufus wright
as chair
uh it went on and on and it was a very
long meeting and we discussed things at
length and i think we came to the right
decision
uh at the end of it what i would like uh
people to make clear is for the people
that are campaigning against it in their
area
those labor politicians which are
scribbling this down now why don't you
make it clear to the residents that you
represent that you put in the local plan
originally
it was your administration that put this
into the local plan
thank you chair
any other comments
thank you chair i i think um it's it's
perfectly honest to say i think this is
becoming a little bit too political and
a little bit too much about events
but the whole purpose of this motion
and the reason why i'm seconding this
and i mean historically i've been an
underwriter i've done jury service twice
and a certain licensing committee as
well as planning
when you're making an assessment
you can only do it with the information
that you have
the key point and no one is disputing
irrespective whether they agree with it
the decision that was made all the
process that we went through planning
the key thing here is that information
came to light subsequent
even the law was changed after 800 years
on double jeopardy that a jury would
re-hear a case if new evidence came to
light
that is what this motion is asking for
that is what is being put before council
and if we are doing the things
appropriately to protect the public that
we are there this should be going back
to planning committee for them to make a
decision with all of the facts that they
did not have at that point in time that
is why i'm supporting this and that is
why the motion is on the table
thank you i'm glad you clarified that
because the second of the motion was
council
reader any other comments
if not then
the proposal to respond counter shipment
thank you chair um
what's happened is what i didn't want to
happen in this meeting it's turned into
a punch and judy show and we're getting
into the detail about how the decision
was made nobody's questioning the fact
that it went to planning it was approved
that we know that's happened but like
david council angus just said we have
new evidence that's come to light new
concerns have been raised by the local
flood authority and we need to make sure
that both sides of the argument can be
reheard with all the information
all right with all the information
available i think that that's only fair
i think what i mean what message does it
send to residents in northeast
derbyshire if we won't even consider
looking at new evidence
i think that that's a failure in the
process if also on earth council are not
willing to send an issue back to the
planning committee personally i think
this should be it should automatically
go back like like the double jubilee
case when there's more information
i think
[Music]
but i seriously think it needs to go to
planning so it can be looked at
independently rather than this punching
judy you're to blame you end on that
we've done that we're the best your crap
i think we seriously need to send it
back and let the planning members of the
planning committee look at it again with
an independent mind with the new
information thank you chair
thank you council shipment so it has
been proposed and seconded
all those in favor of the motion
[Music]
all those against
[Music]
any abstentions
that's it the vote
has been cast the motion has been lost
move to the next motion submitted by
councillor barker over to you please
council banker thank you chair
am i on
come on
thank you for that
uh hopefully you've all got that motion
in front of you i will not read it out
word for word
but i think just before i start i'd like
to
praise the government and
uh our council and the the staff
for what uh during the pandemic because
i think uh
you know we are inside we could argue
some different things but i think
overall
uh
we've managed that pandemic really well
and and obviously jane's team and
everything at the council
to to forward that you know the
introduction of the fellow scheme the
grants to councils and businesses
uh the stopping of evictions
and helping the homeless
you know we can't fault all that and
last but not least the uplift to the 20
pound a week universal credit
were a good thing
and whilst we there was and i think
there is an acceptance that most of
these schemes count one forever
we believe the 20 pound uplift is
different
i'm sure you've all seen or read about
the difference the money has made to
people's lives and it don't feel right
to me and to us now to take that away
so
not only that but the 40 percent of
households or so we're told also work so
they're going to have to pay the
increase in national insurance what they
call a double whammy i think
and as you can see from the motion we're
also calling on the council
as you can see you know to write to the
council asking for the 20 pound uplift
to be made permanent
also and and i think this is something
i've always been a concern of mine
this wait i mean to wait five weeks for
a universal credit and if if you're
getting in dire straits you can have a
loan that you've got paid back and i've
never been comfortable with that not
comfortable universal credit to be
honest
that needs a culture looking at but i
think oh you know to to change that to
loans rather than grants i think that's
a reasonable thing
and finally the third bullet point which
is about working together
and i know there's been
a nick up with the with the links scheme
and and the other things and i know the
council does support all the
uh
like
citizens advice and things like that but
with that in mind uh i i just like asked
the council having a look at that
decision regarding the links and i know
there's a nickel i know there's been any
cup there
so with all that in mind i'd like to
move the motion as printed in the papers
thank you
thank you do you have a second er yes
chair
thank you this is kelsey pickering thank
you chair can you hear me
i think this is a vitally important uh
issue for
our residents in northeast darvish so
i'm very happy to second this motion and
i'd like to reserve my right to reply
thank you
any comments
council shipment
thank you chair i absolutely support
this motion i think
it's something that we need to support
there's a lot of people that are
struggling at the minute
like councillor um barca said it's a
double whammy for a lot of them because
they're also paying the increase in
taxes that's that's been announced by
the government and i think that we need
to keep this uplift otherwise there's
gonna be more people going into poverty
and we're gonna have to end up paying
that we're gonna end up having to pay it
out twice again anyway when they're
collecting other benefits or
and and they just can't support
themselves so i think we seriously need
to
write for the government and make our
feelings heard
thank you
any other comments counselor dale
thank you uh chair
wait until
my arm
everyone hear me okay brilliant
thank you
[Music]
none of us here would argue that this
has not been a an extremely tough time
for families across the district and i
think we can all accept that kovid has
thrown up some tremendous challenges
across society
and the impact on the economy
and more important people's livelihoods
has been very severe
and i also hope we can all agree that as
a council we have done a lot to support
our communities
through the pandemic including
vulnerable households so i hope that the
sympathy and desire to which this
administration holds for those who are
struggling would not be in question
but nor can we forget or ignore the
lengths that the government has gone to
prop up the economy throughout the
pandemic and to soften the blow to our
most disadvantaged residents and i'm
pleased that council barca has
acknowledged that but i just want to
talk for a few moments just to to
highlight the scale of the
levels of support that have gone into
into the economy and into supporting
people recent figures suggested over the
course of the pandemic 350 billion
pounds was invested by the government to
create support and protect jobs and
businesses as well as a range of other
measures
to support wider society
the list was practically endless there
was nearly 70 billion spent on the
furlough scheme 25 billion spent on the
self-employed income support scheme 31
billion pounds on the business
interruption loan scheme there was the
cobric covid corporate finance facility
the local restrictions grant additional
restrictions grant mandatory business
grants that we distributed as a district
council there were the test and trace
self-isolation grants again that we
distributed the council a 47 billion
pound bounce-back loan scheme
a 500 million pound future fund a 1.6
million pound kickstart scheme to create
jobs for young people currently in
receipt of universal credit as well as a
range of other
schemes to support apprenticeships
traineeships
to give refunds of statutory sick pay
for businesses
to relax annual leave there was some
targeted support so to specific
industries uh like culture and tourism
uh culture and the arts rather a 1.5
5 billion pound package there a huge
packet of package of support to councils
like our own and that is to just to name
a few
there were further measures to help
families and individual individuals
directly such as mortgage holidays
support for renters support with energy
bills
council tax hardship support
an additional 7.4 billion pounds went
into
additional money went into the welfare
system to support those on low incomes
and we also had
an item that i know council barca will
have discussed with me a number of times
at the viper meetings we had over 300
million pounds on the covered winter and
local grant scheme that you'll be aware
the county council used to support free
school meal
and title families as well as the 220
million pound holiday activities and
food programme and most recently in the
past few days we've had the 500 million
pound household support fund
announced just last week and will be
targeted at vulnerable households i
think when you really stop to think
about it the level of support the
government have put in place
to protect our economy businesses and
households is quite frankly astounding
and while entirely necessary during the
pandemic we do have to accept that
almost all of this has come from
borrowing the cost of which will impact
on the uk for generations to come and we
have to be extremely mindful of this
when considering these issues
i for one am not content to continually
pile more national debts on our children
and grandchildren and constrain their
opportunities prosper
as a country we continue to spend more
on servicing the interest on our debts
than we do on defence public safety and
order transport housing and environment
and a range of other forms of public
spending
for me this is simply not sustainable
for the long term
the increase to universal credit credit
was only announced as a temporary
measure back in march 2020 and it was
part of a wide range of packages of
support that were put in place that i've
already been through and since then the
government has put in place all of the
measures i've highlighted and more
recently it's multi-million pound plan
for jobs
measures like the kickstart program have
seen
over 260 thousand approved rolls created
from a range of different sectors the 16
to 24 year olds on universal credit
uh more recently the 2.5 billion pound
restarted
okay intensive support to over one
million job seekers who've been out out
of work for over a year i think when
taken together the with the continued
efforts to support vulnerable households
including the very recent 500 million
household support fund we feel as a
group that the government has adopted
the right approach by focusing its
efforts on those most in need and on
creating jobs to elevate people out of
hardship particularly as we recover from
the from the pandemic and therefore for
the reasons given we won't be supporting
this motion i would like to respond to
the link's cvs issues but i'll defer to
a colleague to do that
thank you
any other comments
council powell
yes thank you um thank you chair
um
just on the links comment
all i need to say about that is that
when we were reviewing
um our annual
contributions to various voluntary
organizations
um as we need to do to make sure the
council has
full value from it
um we
um
discussed and then published a spec
and for whatever reason and i don't know
why lynx
did not
bother to
apply
thank you
thank you knew the comment
council hancock
thank you chair
um i acknowledge what counselor dale has
said that when this was first introduced
we all knew it was a temporary measure
the reality is the world has moved on
since then and uh whilst he cites the
government's
accomplishments and how it's supported
we've also got to accept that inflation
is now the highest that it's been since
the 1970s we're all paying a lot more
for our shopping than we were when this
was first introduced i go back actually
it was a gift councillor parking made
reference earlier to fuel and utility
costs again they've gone up they've
taken they've increased that cap people
are paying more out
um
in all honesty
and i mean i'm certainly not on
universal credit kind of income but i
would be hurt by 20 pound a week that's
coming out of my money when that could
effectively be my shopping which it is
for a lot of these people it's actually
obscene to consider taking it away
i think it's also ironic that we're
talking about debt and i fully agree
we've got to pay back what we borrow but
we're borrowing money to pay for a yacht
which which again is lunacy so i i mean
as with ross we'll fully be supporting
this motion and i think that taking
taking money away from the hardest hit
in our community which this is
that's not the sign of a
civilized society at all
thank you
the others council kenyan
hi thank you
um yes i won't be supporting the motion
uh it seems to me it's too crude
uh a mechanism a flat 20 pounds it was
brought in in an emergency situation as
a means of providing immediate relief
and what i would say is that things such
as increasing the minimum wage
and which we've been doing above
inflation and creating an environment
where
salaries are not undercut by cheap
foreign labor
is
a better strategy to lift people out of
the need and as was mentioned earlier
many people on universal credit are
actually working
and i think we need to focus our
um support on those who are most needy
and the most vulnerable thank you
[Music]
are you wishing to speak
counter-comwell
no i just want right any other comments
council pickering would you like to
exercise your writing reply
thank you thank you chair um yes
we had an interesting list of uh
expenditure that councillor dale
provided us with
um it's unfortunate that he didn't
separate that out into the money that's
spent actually to help people who are in
need
and the amount of that money that was
spent
um wasted lining people's pockets
billions that were spent
on a wasted and failed track and trace
system
handing contracts out to friends who
used to be landlords the pubs we went
into and giving contracts to people who
went to ex nail bar and eyelash
companies
um
there are still on companies house
there's billions wasted there were
millions supporting people billions
wasted and what we're talking about now
is money that's going directly into
people's pockets immediately
not as councillor kenyon suggests that
we wait another 12 months while we've
come to some wonderful strategies that
might be alternatives people need money
today
the temporary uplift that was announced
last year the start the pandemic will
all be aware of now has been winding
down and it'll finally come to an end at
the end of this week
withdrawing that 20 pound a week uplift
will leave many people and families
across northeast derbyshire facing an
unprecedented squeeze on their household
budgets
um
and for people that's getting a regular
income that's fine but for people that
have run out of money by tuesday and
aren't getting anything else to the end
of the week 20 quid is a life saver it's
not pocket money that we're talking
about here
um
the government's withdrawing this
lifeline just as the country and
northeast derbyshire are facing
significant cost of living crisis
the joseph roundtree foundation has said
that the government will be abandoning
millions to hunger and hardship across
the country by pushing ahead with this
cut
the decision is set to plunge many
people into poverty and it shows a total
disregard for the consequences and we've
heard that from some of the comments
this afternoon from the other side of
this chamber
this winter
people are facing an untenable
combination of increases to the cost of
food and energy
it's more than a triple whammy
they've got rising inflation cost to
food costs to energy the end of the
furlough scheme and an imminent hike to
national insurance contributions
in addition to that it also appears that
according to a recent report
northeast derbyshire is going to be
locked out of the leveling up funding as
well
the government's prioritized 93 areas at
level 1 to be given access to that level
leveling up funding northeast derbyshire
isn't one of them and i hope our mp's
pushing
the government to um reassess its
criteria for for different uh
communities and to look more in depth
rather than the wider affluent areas
that hide the areas of deprivation
within them
um
we need to fight for our residents
people go to the polls expecting that
those elected will fight for their best
interests and i'm saying this afternoon
it's in the best interest of the people
in northeast derbyshire that we try and
prevent them from spiraling further down
into deprivation
to do this
it needs empathy
understanding and compassion
some who have not heard much of this
afternoon
and there is this there is the adage
that compassionate conservatism
as it's known is a bit like a unicorn
many people have heard of it but
nobody's actually seen it
and chair i don't think we're going to
see it again this afternoon
much to some people shame
there's still time for a change of art
however and we need to take action now
it's the responsibility of all
councillors to challenge this cruel and
callous cut at this moment in time it
can be extended and planned for in a
much better way than just cutting people
off from a lifeline that they've had
that's where we are i'm proud to second
this motion and i hope everybody votes
for it this afternoon and looks into the
heart to find the the ability to do that
thank you council pickering so back to
you councillor barker as the proposer
your right of reply thank you chair
am i on
yeah
i think steve's uh well stole my thunder
very good but i've put down here
sometimes in politics you know you get
to a point where you have to consider
why you're doing things and and and
things come on to real so they say and i
feel like this is one of them times i do
feel like i said in the introduction
i don't think the labor government would
have done a lot different to the
conservative government during the
pandemic you know we got to get through
that
however i think the difference now is is
starting to show itself
and the the question is who pays for it
i accept what you say alex you know it
you can't go on forever
we ain't got a bottom lip
pit as they say
but
do we ask those that's got the most or
do we ask those that's got the least to
pay for it and i know which side i'm on
uh and while most of what's been been
said you know there's not been a lot set
actually from the other side but it
don't come as a surprise and and i
appreciate that most of you have been
instructed to vote against this that's
how these things works but i'd urge you
to consider that decision again
individually like steve just said
and i'm sure everyone in the room will
have at least one family in their uh
their ward that will be affected by this
decision
20 pound a week's a lot of money when
you ain't got a lot and
i think we should we should at least and
let's be honest we're not asking a lot
it's not going to cost this council a
penny we're asking to write a letter
to the chancellor to consider a decision
that will that
ultimately will help
the most vulnerable in our communities
that's what we're looking at that's why
it's here today
and i would really urge all of you to
vote for this motion thank you
your counselor so uh
we move to the vote on this motion
can i call for recorded vote chair yeah
i'll second that yeah
so we've had three people then indicate
recorded vote council pickering
councillor
wright
and councillor barker so we will move to
a recorded vote so i'll be asking
governance to take the role
in reverse order
so you'll be asked whether to vote for
the motion against
or abstain
can everyone hear me
[Music]
right councillor p
wright again
councillor be right
four
councillor winley
it's not here
council wheelhouse
council welton
against
council
[Music]
council
against
councillor tate
cancer stone
or
councillor stratford stevenson against
councillor shipman
four
councillor rough
councillor rouse
councillor rowe
council renick
against
council reader
or
councillor powell
against
councillor potts
cancer platz
that was against
council pickering
councillor morley
councillor lilly
for
councillor liggett
against
councillor lewis
against councillor lacey
or
councillor kerry
councillor kenyon against
councillor jones
councillor hutchinson against councillor
homes
[Music]
council homes here yeah
council homes
was that four
against
councillor elliot
[Music]
[Music]
cooper
council cloth
against council birkin or
cancer barry or
council barker for cancer armitage
against council and cliff okay
[Applause]
thank you so the result is 21 votes for
24 against no abstentions therefore the
motion is lost
move to item 11
i move that the public be excluded from
the meeting during the discussion of the
following item of business to avoid the
disclosure to them of exempt information
as defined in paragraphs one two three
and five part one of schedule 12a to the
local government act 1972
as amended by the local government
access to information variation order
2006. do you have a second to please
thank you council ruff
all those in favor
all those against
carried the public is excluded
item 15 um there's no other business
apart from to say that i'm hoping
governance will look at the
the way that we manage meetings in
future
and whether we can or cannot go back to
mill lane um i'm sure most of us would
like to
um in the interests of inclusion
and in the interests of democracy we
should not be meeting in sports halls
with acoustic issues like this so i'm
sure governor should look at it
so thank you all for your attendance and
i declare the meeting